شركه تدفق قوارب الهجره غير النظاميه من
شمال فرنسا الى بريطانيا ارتفاعا لافتان
خلال العام الماضي تجاوز معه عدد الواصلين
الى السواحل البريطانيه
45,000 وهو الاعلى هذا الاطلاق
الداخليه البريطانيه في وقت اكدت فيه
باريس ولندن اتفاقهما على تشديد رقابه
الحدود البحريه بينهما الزميل ماء العينين
لديه المزيد
اعدادهم
المهاجرون غير النظاميين الواصلون الشواطئ
بريطانيا
فرنسا وطريقهم يمر عبر بحر الماش تكشف
ارقام وزاره الداخليه البريطانيه ان خمسه
واربعين الف مهاجرين عبروا بحر الماش على
متن مراكب بدائيه في عام 2022 لان نسبتهم
تضاعفت تقريبا مقارنه بالعام السابق
تظهر احصاءات الداخليه البريطانيه تزايدا
مطاردا لنشاط هذه القوارب في السنوات
الثلاث الاخيره فقد كان عدد الواصلين دون
عشره الاف قبل نحو ثلاث سنوات
ليناهز 30,000 في العام الموالي وتظهر
الارقام الرسميه البريطانيه ان نشاط مراكب
الهجره عبر بحري قماش بلغ او وجهه في
الصيف العام الماضي اذ بلغ عدد الموقوفين
في يوم واحد من اغسطس الماضي نحو 12
90 شخصا كانوا موزعين على 27 مركبا تؤكد
وزاره داخليه البريطانيه ان السوء الاحوال
الجويه لا يعيق نشاط الهجره غير النظاميه
عبر المعاش يتواصلت تدفقات في عز الشتاء
مخلفه ماسي انسانيه اخرها وقايه احصاءات
الداخليه البريطانيه مصرع ثلاثه مهاجرين
في ليله واحده واسطه ديسمبر الماضي وهو
رقم يبدو ضئيل مقارنه بالفتره ذاتها من
عام 2021 الذي شهد مصرع 27 مهاجرا غير
نظامي في ليله واحده ياتي نشر هذه الارقام
في ظل اتفاق فرنسي البريطانيه على تشديد
الرقابه وخطط بريطانيه متتاليه اعدتها
حكومه المحافظين منها اعاده احياء اتفاق
ابريل شهر ابريل الماضي مع رواندا ويهدف
الى طرد اللاجئين الذين وصلوا بصفه غير
الشرعيه دون النظر في طلبات اللجوء
يقدمونها وهو اتفاق الغته المحكمه
الاوروبيه لحقوق الانسان لاحقا وفي منتصف
نوفمبر الماضي التزمت لندن بدفع 72 مليون
يورو لشراء السيارات وتمويل عمليه نشر ما
بين 800 و 900 شرطي وعسكري اضافي في
الشواطئ الفرنسيه للحد من عمليه الهجره
غير النظاميه وكان رئيس الحكومه
البريطانيه ريتش صناعه قد قدم في الشهر
الماضي خطه لطرد اللاجئين القادمين من دول
سماها بالامنه فضلا عن اتفاق اخر مع
السلطات تيرانا لطرد جماعي للاجئين
الالبان يبدو اذا انه عزم بريطاني فرنسي
على التعامل بشكل جدي ونهائي مع مشكله
الهجره غير النظاميه بين ضيفتي بحر المعاش
للمزيد تنضم الينا من بروكسل الدكتوره
مارتا ولاندر الخبيره في شؤون الهجره
واللجوء والمديره التنفيذيه سابقه لمؤسسه
حقوق اللاجئين في اوروبا الدكتوره مارتا
رغم الاجراءات البريطانيه المتشدده بالطرد
والنقل الى دول اخرى العام الماضي شهداء
التدفق الاكثر لعدد اللاجئين الغير
نظاميين الى بريطانيا كيف نفسر هذه
الثنائيه
بدايه فان الارتفاع
الذي حصل مؤخرا
لبحر الماش يعكس زياده
عالميه في اعداد اللاجئين والمهاجرين حسب
احصائيات الامم المتحده وايضا اعداد
النازحين ايضا تضاعف عالميا عام 201
ينعكس في اوروبا منذ عام 2015
تحديدا راينا هذه الزياده الحاده في عدد
الاشخاص الذين يعبرون بحر الماء في قوارب
صغيره كان هنالك 300 شخص في عام 2018
الزياده فيها اعداد هذه القوارب الصغيره
مقارنه
اساليب الاخرى هو ياتي نتيجه لزياده
لتامين الطرق الاخرى بمعنى ان الاجراءات
التي اتخذتها السلطات البريطانيه
والفرنسيه على الطرق الاخرى ادت الى زياده
عدد القوارب الصغيره واذا يمكن ان نرى هو
نتيجه همم
انسحاب بريطانيا من تنظيمات
بالتالي دفع الاشخاص او المهاجرين الى
اتباع اساليب او اللجوء الى هذه الطرق
لذلك كما قلت انها ما نراه نتيجه
للقيود اللي صارمه على الحدود ادى همم الى
ودفعت المهاجرين
والمهربين عفوا والافراد الى اتخاذ هذا
الطريق وهذا الامر اخذ
تجاره
المهربين مهربي البشر وشبيقات العامله في
هذا
الا قطع والذين استغلوا ياسا الاشخاص
الذين يريدون عبور بحر
الماشيلطات البريطانيه والفرنسيه مكافحه
هذه الظاهره بالقول ان من ياتون الى
شواطئها او معظم الاتينا الى هذه الشواطئ
هم
ياتون من دول امنه الى اي مدى هذا يعكس
الواقع باعتقادك
علينا انه اكد على ان اغلبيه الاشخاص وحسب
الاحصائيات هنالك 94% من الاشخاص الذين
يصلون بهذه القوارب الصغيره في حقيقه
الامر يقدمون طلبات اللجوء
وهذا بالتاكيد هو حق لهم حسب القانون
الدولي وعلى القانون الدولي الانسانيه
وايضا نعرف ان بعض
الجنسيات همم
ياخذ هذه القواربهم من الافغان ومن
الايرانيين والعراقيين والسوريين بالتالي
هذا يخبرنا عن اسباب او خلفيه الاشخاص
الذين يتركون بلادهم بالاضافه الى ذلك كما
قلت فان الحج التي تقدمها بعض
السلطات البريطانيه والفرنسيه حول انهم
ياتون من بلدان امنه ليس همم مطلب حسب
القانون الدولي للاشخاص لكي يقدمه اللجوء
في
البلد الاول الذي يصل اليهما ينص عليه
القانون الدولي ان المسؤوليه الاولى للدول
من اجل تحديد اللاجئين وعرض الحمايه
الدوليه الامر تقع بين يدي الدوله حيث يصل
اللاجئين ويقدمون انفسهم على انهم يسعون
لطلب اللجوء شكرا
الهجره واللجوء والمديره التنفيذيه
السابقه لمؤسسه حقوق اللاجئين في اوروبا
من بروكسل